ça m'agace radio tour d'espagne l'otan
cherche à vous en présence du ministre
des affaires étrangères turc même si tu
cherches oglou suivie d'une réunion
tripartite en présence d'une affaire
étrangères ukrainien couler bas sèche le
rend plus fort a été tenue à
l'initiative
de la partie turque a proposé à au
président possible nous avons accepté
cette proposition
proposition des collègues surtout
parce que nous sommes en faveur de tous
les copains
contact pour pouvoir trouver une issue
du conflit ukrainien et pour trouver les
solutions de sortie de ce conflit ces
contacts doivent avoir une valeur
ajoutée et ne doivent pas être détournés
ou utilisés par nos collègues ukrainiens
aux ministres de 502
désavoué où
je vole et
des pourparlers entre deux
délégations
russe et ukrainienne
la réunion d'aujourd'hui a montré que ce
dialogue n'a pas d'alternative sont ils
à
l'initiative de nos amis turcs nous
avons à parler des questions
humanitaires dans chauveau l'yonne nous
avons expliqué les actions et les
décisions prises par nos forces armées
sur place pour soulager la population
qui lui est en majorité
prisa en otage par les volontaires soit
disant par les forces de la défense
terrestre
ce sont des faits bien avérée bien connu
un représentant il compile représentant
du ministère de la défense russe
tiennent au courant de ces faits les
initiatives
russes notamment ont été prises pour
mettre en place des couloirs
humanitaires
tout cela reste opérationnel
[Musique]
modalités 2
des couloirs ouverture au minitère
humanitaires sont toujours décédé sur
place
sur le terrain étant donné les intérêts
de la population civile
lors de la dernière session des
pourparlers hop et la russe la partie
russe a fait une proposition concrète
et la partie ukrainienne
récupérer ces propositions écrites et
nous a promis de nous je n'ai je la hais
réponses concrètes nous pensons qu'il
est important de négocier sans quand je
n'écoute les chats
transmettre les informations
non officielles de négocier ce que tu
des
solutions concrètes pour pouvoir sortir
de cette crise pour pouvoir assurer la
sécurité sur le continent européen dans
les intérêts de tous les pays
je reste bref
et sur ce je suis ouvert à vos questions
première chaîne russie
à vous
à
l'étal aux la partie turque
[Musique]
mal
votre oncle en euros de ce magazine in
style art déco
à ce que l'issue de la messe est une
pratique
les secteurs
du new in town of toulouse je n'ai pas
tout saisi mais
si lorsque les questions sur le
délitement de l'opération spéciale
militaire et bien cette analyse est
donné par le représentant du ministère
de la défense et puis le plus important
cette analyse est donné par le pdg
footing l'opération se déroule comme
prévu luthier en ce qui concerne
parce qu'au
support de l'étranger
inquiet de la réaction et dangereuse de
la part de nos partenaires
occidentaux
nous voyons qui les encouragent les
livraisons d armes
extrêmement dangereuse par des milliers
des
systèmes
de roquettes et ces systèmes sont
souvent utilisés pour pouvoir menacer
l'aviation
civile
la question que nous nous posons de
savoir quelle est la destination de ces
milliers de
complexes et des lance missiles et des
lance roquettes
reçues non voyons
que il y avait la menace et ukrainienne
contre la russie non vous trouvons
toujours pas de réponse à cette question
c'est une situation qui va durer des
chalets et elle la menace pourrait se
répandre dans toute l'europe en ce qui
concerne votre question de savoir si
nous avons l'intention d'attaquer
d'autres pays eh bien nous n'avons pas
cette intention et nous n'avons pas à
tchèque et l'ukraine nous nous nous
sommes retrouvés dans une situation avec
des menaces directes contre la
fédération de russie ça faisait des
années que nous avancions des
propositions les propositions qui sont
restées lettre moi c'est un président
poutine on en parlait en profondeur et
la situation dans l
les régions de donetsk est lougansk
montre que l'invasion et l'attaquent les
attaques contre ces territoires ont été
planifiés en profondeur en détail depuis
des mois et des mois nous voyons des
faits qui nous
indigne
selon lesquelles que sur le financement
américain
les laboratoires d'ukrainiens sont
utilisés pour mettre en place des
expérimentations afin de créer une arme
biologique
les représentants de washington ont
dénoncé ont reçu très ouvertement ces
faits mais ce n'est pas surprenante et
le fait que l'union européenne à
l'unisson du cube a dit qu' ils n'ont
par une information qui confirmerait que
les américains
font des
actions qui vont vers la création de ces
armes ce n'est pas surprenant
bien sûr les américains
ont tenu à ces actions se crée tout
comme il
tout cela sur tout l'espace un post
soviétique en jetons et bien évidemment
nous ne pouvons pas fermer les yeux là
dessus il existe la convention qui
interdit l'utilisation et la création
des stars mois chimiques et un top 6
et bien sûr il faudrait
que les la responsabilité soit un sur
nbc j'espère que j'ai répondu à votre
question
et le
encourage le pen a développé ses aux
armes à ils doivent être tenus pour
responsables et assumer leurs
responsabilités tout comme tous ceux qui
un courage d'envoyer à une ukraine des
volontaires et des mares mercenaires
seront jamais assez de prendre ma
question je représente si nbc news
avec s'annonce pas choisi la russie à
utiliser
nombre de mots pour justifier l'invasion
de l'ukraine dit que c'est pour le
peuple ukrainien mais comment est-ce que
vous pouvez justifier le bombardement
d'une maternité d'un hôpital pédiatrique
le fait de cibler des femmes enceintes
et des enfants il s'agit d'une atrocité
et pour le peuple russie même
aujourd'hui la russie fait face à un
défaut de 40 milliards de dollars c'est
le pire qu'ait connue l'économie russe
depuis la révolution et 1917 qu'est ce
que vous dites au peuple russe qui
payent le prix d'une invasion que le
reste du monde réprouve merci beaucoup
concernant la maternité
ce n'est pas la première fois que nous
voyons des déclarations pathétiques
sur soi disant des exactions
qui seraient
exécutés par les forces russes le 7 mars
bien de lui si je suis pas sûr
la réunion du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu la russie a
montré l'effet du bataillon ou d'azov
sur
sur notamment les actions qui ont amené
à chasser
tous les tous les personnels médical les
données qui datent d'il ya trois jours
montrent qu'il
s'agit d'une
base à
chaud il était vous pouvez toujours à
vérifier ces informations
les déclarations ont été très émotionnel
mais
il ya toujours un revers de la médaille
ces objectifs ne tire pas suffisamment
d'attention
ce qui concerne
la solidité de la fédération de russie
notre situation est
entre les mains de notre gouvernement
entre le manque du président poutine
vous parlez des possibilités de
justifier
csn et bien la russie lui a parlé des
actions à mener par l'ukraine depuis des
années
lorsque
bien
entendu
de la part des occidentaux lorsqu'il
disait à l'ukraine c'est à vous de
choisir d'être à côté de l'occident ou
du côté de la russie
ne sont pas des déclarations à tenir il
me semble qu'en 2009
en violation de la constitution sont
deux secrets l'ouest store enfourché la
cour
constitutionnelle a de l'effet la
mettre en place le troisième tour des
élections présidentielles et des
violations comme cela on était
multiple à ces années là personne ne
disait rien il s'agit d'une d'un
incident pilote des occidentaux et bien
sûr et lorsque le temps
d'assurer la liberté de l'ukraine
liberté de choisir d'adhérer à le temps
et lorsque nous avons déjà vu la
création des bases de l'otan à l'ukraine
et menaces d du développement du missile
mais est maintenant un ces menaces est
renforcée par la création des
laboratoires de
des armes biologiques
et
c'est à ce moment là nous avons un peu
les yeux nos partenaires occidentaux
puisque tu as
raison garder
et nous avons obtenu est la juste
réponse que nous pouvions faire des
déclarations mais la question de
l'adhésion à l'oedt ans et est
indiscutable et
pourquoi
garantie de notre sécurité doit être
discuté et décidé par le temps
ce n'est pas dans nos intérêts de
justifier quoi que ce soit à une ukraine
il fait nous ne souhaitons pas la
militarisation de l'ukraine en dur de le
temps où à l'intérieur de l'otan même en
dehors de l'adhésion a le temps il est
tout à fait possible
mesdames militarisé le cred nous ne
souhaitons pas à l'état néo nazis annuel
avec des traditions néonazis et lorsque
bataillon défilent avec
des signes
de néo nazis
dans les rues
et bien nous ne souhaitons pas non plus
des actes terroristes
heineken nous souhaitons que l'ukraine
ne soit neutre le président poutine a
dit à de nombreuses reprises
qu'il en restait là dessus nous ne
souhaitons pas
enlever la sécurité à
l'ukraine non nous souhaitons assurer la
sécurité de l'europe de l'ukraine et de
la russie
maintenant les signaux de la part du
président celles et ceux qui me côtoient
il serait à l'écouté de ses demandes ça
renforce
ça donne un espoir si nous
faisons face à des situations sont clic
et ce n'est pas la première fois dans
notre histoire mais je vous assure
que
nous sommes tous les anneaux n'est que
tu peux nous ressortir de cette crise un
plus fort nous n'avons aucune illusion
sur le fait que l'occident
oui la vérité et
nous n'aurons aucune illusion sur le
fait que l'occident à
trahir ses propres valeurs a
dit
plus que le mouvement se fait
résolution
d'innocence qui était dans piliers
des valeurs
soient
détruits sur je vous assure que nous
allons ou non du tueur s'en sortir
nous n'allons pas faire de compromis
dans des oeufs en ce qui concerne les
intérêts russes
première chaîne à vous
bonjour quand c'était quelqu'un de jeune
première
j'aimerais bien aussi si c'était les
dernières informations de kiev
représentants et responsables de
l'administration présidentielle petit
que tous les pourparlers doivent se
tenir ou au niveau des présidents pensez
vous que ce serait une bonne idée
d'organiser la réunion au niveau des
présidents
nous sommes en faveur de tous les
comptes à d'impossibles
sinon
souhaitons que ces contacts puisse
donner lieu à des apports chef le
ministre couler bas
a évoqué ses propositions j'ai rappeler
encore une fois que nous sommes prêts à
dialoguer pour pouvoir trouver une
solution
il l'ukraine après
le coup d'état
anticonstitutionnel préfère des
simulations et le
simulacre au lieu des pourparlers pour
pour voir soi disant trouver des
solutions souvenez-vous des accords
d'oslo de minsk elle north qui ester
est restée lettre morte
et le président zelensky est appelée à
se réunir
rappelons que les
dernières la réunion où format normandie
en décembre 2019 et que cette semaine
cette réunion n'avait pas donné lieu à
des
réalisations des accords de minsk est
bien à quoi bon
organiser un autre ce messie le sommet
précédent nage pas donné des résultats
concrets et bien souvenez vous
lorsqu'il ya eu des propositions
d'élargir le format normandie afin de
par exemple intégrer lettres sur qui
d'autre un partenaire il ya eu des
propositions de créances plus des
groupes de contact élargi bien d'autres
initiatives de qui avance qui pourront
être expliqué très simplement
et de substituer ses
responsabilités par des déclarations qui
donne en effet ea
qui semble
opérationnel je répète il est important
de continuer nos efforts dans le cadre
des pourparlers au
bélarus
nous attendons des propositions et des
réponses concrètes
nous avons des représentants des médias
ukrainiens à vous
sur lavrov
lorsque je suis la russie entre temps
sur les terres avant de démilitariser et
onu dainese méfier
il ya toujours des chances qu ont par
exemple écrit mais aujourd'hui nous
voyons que gibrat guimauve à hay
river john dow des fans
qui a été kidnappée
et bien je
tarde et la crimée souffrent ce sont des
faits et disparaissent quelle est votre
réaction
vous avez dit que ce sont des faits eh
bien je ne pense pas que ce sont des
faits on peut qualifier cela par un
autre mot qui commence par f
non je ne suis pas au courant de cette
histoire de la disparition d'une reprise
en temps nous des députés
mais la façon dont se comporte et le
régime qui est bien
nous étonne pas comme quoi il hier nous
avons entendu
parler de la disparition de shevchenko
ou que
krief et tu es et tu es soit disant
parce que il l'a trayons secret d'état
si nous nous intéressons à des histoires
personnelles non secours y ont
effectivement trouvé le des faits sinon
andine
dangereux de
juste extirpé a fait du contexte et et
c'est
autour de ce fier encore une fois c'est
une substitution
du travail de négociation
si
les noms sauf peut-être également listé
à l'infini je me renseignerai je ne t'ai
pas au courant j'ai entendu parler de la
disparition de shevchenko qui pourrait
étaient
distincts qui a disparu
je sais non voudra bien lui donner la
possibilité de poser des questions à
vous soniques et bien je pense que vous
aurez l'information qui vous intéressera
chez vous
prenez le microphone la question
suivante
quel match vous
nous voudrions bien donner la parole au
représentant de l'italie merci
démonstration de la démocratie
le pouvoir parle de l'utilisation
d'armes board biologique qu'est ce que
vous en dites au dos quinze ans que je
viens au nez nous sommes très préoccupés
par les informations selon lesquelles
le pentagone ou à créer quelques
dizaines de laboratoires
des laboratoires militaires
biologique heineken en violation de la
convention
de l'internet sur l'interdiction ou non
de la des armes biologiques non
allons demander des réponses et des
explications
je n'ai pas d'informations sur un emploi
l'emploi de ces armes
mais le fait que qu'il y avait des
expériences menées pour mettre au point
les armes biologiques cette information
est tout nous l'avons sans aucun doute
izvestia c'est à vous
supplie
victorovitch les états unis déclarent
ouvertement
en appelant les pays du monde entier à
se joindre aux
sanctions qui ont été instaurées est ce
que vous vous vous appelez
vos
ambassadeurs à se réunir contre ces
sanctions
eh bien nous tenons nos ambassadeurs
informé
que les informations
objectives sont communiquées par nos
ambassadeurs dans le monde entier
le fait de
d'appliquer timber hill d'exécuter des
ordres de dents frère un grand frère ne
s'est pas partie de nos traditions
le fait également que
au niveau
de demande de notamment adressé à la
chine d'appliquer
à des sanctions américaines c'était
ça dépasse tout entendement
nous nous nous livrons pas à de tels
actes sky news à vous
monsieur le ministre ce canadien coincé
le royaume uni
vous avez dit à quelques temps que la
russie n'avait aucune intention
d'envahir l'ukraine aujourd'hui vous
avez dit que la russie n'avait pas
envahi le créneau mais c'est un fait
elle l'a fait vous avez dit que la
russie ne ciblerait pas deux civils
alors que des milliers de civils ont été
touchés ainsi dès des bâtiments comment
est ce qu'on peut vous croire
comment prendre au sérieux vos propos
ce qui concerne les hôpitaux
et les maternités j'ai déjà dit roddick
mais vous allez pas le transmettre
nous avons déjà expliqué ce qui s'était
passé dans cet hôpital dans cette
maternité au conseil de ce qui était
devenu il ya trois jours maintenant ce
qui se passera ou ce qui ne se passera
pas je vous répondrais un sou nous avons
fait tous jusqu'au bout pour trouver une
solution diplomatique
nous avons proposé les discussions
approfondies sur toutes les questions de
la sécurité
d'accor la participation des états unis
avec participation de l'ukraine on nous
a répondu que l'ukraine était annoncé
que c'était un ange de décider du sort
de le pen sur
absolument tous les aspects nous
président poutine a expliqué très de
façon très claire les raisons de cette
opération militaire
spéciale
et donc vous pouvez lire ses
explications qui
on s'était donné qu'ils se trouvent sur
le site officiel l'ukraine sera en pays
amical
démilitarisé sans menaces fusent dans
quel état néonazis un pays dans lequel
qui lui raconte le seul à
la langue russe qui ne sera pas banni la
culture russe et l'église et pendant ses
huit ans après le coup d'état
constitutionnel
heineken pendant tout ce temps là nous
avons fait des propositions dans ce sens
qu'ils n'ont pas été écoutés
lorsque la loi ukrainienne
minorités les droits des minorités invs
été
adopté et qui portait également sur
l'existence uniquement de la langue
ukrainienne sans la langue russe
la hongrie
bulgarie
d'autres pays ont
dénoncé cela mais l'ukraine
à je fais juste une exception schoder
d'en haut sans dans le cadre de cette
loi
l'ukraine
assurer la possibilité de parler des
langes gorge de l'union européenne en
ukraine et cela a calmé les esprits
l'ouest et donc cela je trouve que
l'ouest souhaite des actions anti russe
nous voyons des doubles standards
comme c'était le cas à côte au roux il
n'y avait pas eu de menaces mais le
temps a saisi cette opportunité pour
pouvoir bombarder
et
lorsque l'indépendance avait été déclaré
et l'occident à celle oui cette décision
pour
[Musique]
justifier de la liberté du monde
pourquoi les
albanais au kosovo se le permettre
le
royaume uni a toujours par exemple
souhaité que
j'étais parmi les pays baltes signé
pense que d'un grand pays puissant ça
c'était une position connue
nous avons bien compris qu'il s'agissait
pas du taux de l'ukraine mais qu'il
s'agissait de l'agression de tout ce qui
est russe cultures langues sécurité etc
et la réaction occidentale à nos
actions et une réaction effréné
cela
montre qu'il s'agit en fait c'est une
question de vie ou de mort
nous devrions rester sur la carte du
monde en défendant nom d'intérêts
je représente ici vie merci monsieur le
ministre
le ministre des affaires étrangères
ukrainien affirmé qu'il n'y avait pas
d'avancées sur un cessez le feu ma
question est la suivante
est ce qu'il y a eu une issue positive
quelles qu'elles soient à cette réunion
merci beaucoup
je l' ai déjà dit au départ que nous
sommes arrivés ici
pour substituer les pourparlers
proposée par le président de la russie
le président de l'ukraine les
pourparlers qui se déroulent au bélarus
c'est là où toutes les questions
politiques sont débattus je sais là bas
les propositions sont faites pour la
pour démilitariser pour assurer la
neutralité de l'est prennent etc
c'est là où eux les pourparlers se
déroulent
sinon nous avons averti nos collègues
jusqu'aujourd'hui que nous n'allons pas
créer les sessions parallèles des
pourparlers en parallèle
mais ça nous étonne pas de voir que les
ukrainiens veulent
créer des
cessions et des formats parallèle qui
substitue
l'essentiel pour pouvoir promouvoir et
leurs activités soit disantes à ses
instances
je ne suis pas surpris
je me suis collé pas
signalé que
[Musique]
cessez le feu n'avait pas été obtenue
s'était pas non plus être l'objectif
est bien les questions
et les propositions d'instaurer lé
c'est le feu les propositions des
couloirs humanitaires par ci qu'on parle
à ceux qui nous correspond pas à des
propositions russes tout cela pour juste
à montrer que la russie n'a pas tendu la
main j'ai bien cette façon de
communiquer
est une façon bien connue ukrainienne
qui vise à substituer un réel travail de
fond
question suivante
merci
question suivante les etats-unis ont
interdit les importations de pétrole et
de gaz russe
quelle est la politique
étrangère de la russie vis-à-vis de
l'europe et ensuite concernant les
sanctions comment est-ce que la russie
réagi face aux sanctions imposées par
différents pays et différentes
entreprises ans il me semble que j'ai
déjà évoqué cette question
votre collègue a posé la même question
l'europe nous allons résoudre cette
question suscite de telle façon
pour que nous ne soyons jamais
dépendants de nos partenaires à
l'occident que ce soient des partenaires
dans le monde des entreprises ou des
partenaires gouvernementaux
nous subissons une
[Musique]
agression jeu politique économique de
l'occident un hymne au but nous allons
chez que prendre des mesures contre ce
jour neuf pour défendre notre économie
et nous aurait dû faire cela il ya
longtemps
maintenant
j'avais parlé des sanctions ça c'était
ma réponse maintenant pour ce qui
concerne le pétrole et le casa
ces questions
nous collègues occidentaux nous n'avons
jamais utilisé
et le pétrole et le gaz
en tant qu instrument d'oppression
il y a eu la première crise lorsque les
ukrainiens ont commencé à voler à
détourner le gaz
à cette époque là la russie livret et le
gaz à l'occident dans le cadre de tous
les accords et les ukrainiens ont
commencé à détourner ses livraisons et
l'occident à l'époque a
dénoncé ces faits et on
se disait que c'était un instrument bon
jugement
chez les autres ont une arme
maintenant nous voyons que l'ukraine
utilisez un tant qu'outil de l'europort
qui pourrait endiguer la russie
donc cela pourrait expliquer en quelques
sortes les valeurs des européennes il ya
des sanctions des interdictions un
à destination de toutes les entreprises
européennes de s'implanter en russie de
réussite est de rester en russie
et bien si vous souhaitez arrêter l
achat d
hydrocarbures
non aux représentants ont déjà être
répondu qu' on allons pas imposer non
résident rocard pur nous avons nos
marchés
livraison déjà qu'ils existent
bonjour merci de prendre la question
j'ai représenté westwood john
parce que la russie a des lignes rouges
en ce qui concerne l'assistance
militaire
concernant le fait de prendre des
mesures sur le plan militaire
je n'ai pas compris avant de prendre des
mesures sur le plan militaire contre qui
est bien contre des pays qu'ils
enverraient de l'aide militaire est ce
que vous avez des lignes rouges
par exemple de nombreux pays envoient de
l'aide militaire à l'ukraine est ce que
il y a une ligne rouge pour vous
concernant cet envoi avant de fonder
mesure
j'ai déjà répondu à la question
la question de savoir si nous allons
réagir à
au fait que les filles sont l'intention
d'ares mais le pen nous pensons que ces
pays crée une menace colossal vis-à-vis
de même lorsqu'il livre des lance
roquettes
en ukraine
et lorsqu'ils voient que ses armes ces
fusils c'est moyens d'artillerie sont
distribués par milliers aux 102 ch et
l'ukraine n'ont
aucun
plan en ce qui concerne et les pays
membres de l'otan
ma collègue
déclaré
simon du plaisir est vrai chez michel et
ne bougeait
pas dix ans poutine la
misa traces qui a dit que poutine ne
s'arrêtera pas
le président poutine ira plus loin et
attaquera la pologne et les pays baltes
et bien je pense que c'est dans l'esprit
de la diplomatie re le britannique
qui est l'esprit de répandre des
informations fausses
évidences donc touche tous aujourd'hui
humour british
gt l'impossible est devenu
pensez vous qu'une guerre nucléaire
pourrait commencer
je ne veux pas chaud croire je n'y crois
pas j'attire votre attention sur le fait
que le thème nucléaire
dans le cadre du contest store dès les
événements et l'ukraine n'a depuis des
mois d'ailleurs à ce sujet ce thème à
nucléaire a été évoquée uniquement par
les représentants de l'occident par les
représentants de le temps lisa trace
aujourd'hui nous l'avons déjà évoqué
avec déclaré qu'elle n'excluait pas de
conflit entre la russie et le temps
comment elle a dû le dire monsieur
spielberg
fait des déclarations de façon
indépendante
on dit donc
mais
armand pourrait être déployé à l'est
monsieur le drian et qui a déclaré par
exemple est rappelé que la france était
aussi en état doté
d'autres déclarations
que l'ouest où l'occident a déclaré à la
russie la guerre totale
ou bien le président joe biden
à la question
s'il ya une alternative à des sanctions
occidentales
monsieur madonna a répondu qu' il ya
juste eu la troisième guerre mondiale en
tant qu'alternative à ses fonctions bien
sûr que cela nous préoccupe c'est
préoccupant lorsqu'on voit que
l'occident
suit ce schéma
le président to sky et fort à du
kazakhstan a proposé son pays comme
médiateur dans la crise en